another thing that i really
um related to even this morning
you know my kids talk about
how you know when you're a parent you're
emotional oh my god and um
yeah i have i i have a big problem with
this like i cry a lot
um and i know like when we were growing
up men you you you're not a man if you
cry but i'm going too far the other way
where i'm like like like like it's it's
it's it's
commercials commercials now they're just
like we're just going to try to make you
cry as quick as in 30 seconds
and there was one this year i don't even
know what it was for but it was like
this old it was christmas right oh did
you see this one okay if christmas now
they just think they pull your heart out
of your chest and they squeeze it and
they say happy holidays
so it's an old man and he picks up like
a kettlebell you know and he like picks
it up and does like that and i'm like
where are they going with this
and then you realize the reason he's
doing that is
[Music]
is uh because he was planning on going
to see his granddaughter and he wanted
to pick her up
i'm just like
like
like
like an old italian like widow
i cannot wait to show this to my two
daughters because that's i mean i'm
constantly we went to see sing and
spiderman we've been going back to the
movies a lot
and
every movie i'm just sobbing the whole
time sing two sing two then i'm like out
of goon through the pig he's working
hard that moment
spider-man like took me down like heavy
life themes
too much um and then there is the things
we turn to to also lighten our mood i
also love a mystery and i love who done
it so you've got this all in one with
this stellar cast crazy a bunch who are
luckily coming on the show this week so
it's kind of like the after party week
on the show it's the after party week on
drew everyone
okay
it's a high school reunion that's how
you set it up and then each episode is
its own genre and
each episode of this show right so
everyone gets together for the reunion
and this one guy dave franco who's kind
of this pop star dies yeah
each episode is from the point of view
of one of the suspects and each of those
episodes is in a genre that corresponds
to that suspect so you got sam
richardson so interesting he's like a
romantic guy so he's like a rom-com
right like
i don't know uh never been kissed okay
whatever uh and then i am uh kind of a
sad middle-aged guy so i'm all about
action movies
and i love your characters so much like
at word go i'm in with you in this
he's a guy who's trying to do right by
his family
and he sees himself as like vin diesel
um but in reality he's more like i don't
know
vin scully no no
just he's just a sad kind of a guy going
through a hard time but he thinks of
himself as like this hardcore action
star which in itself is very sad but and
sadness
is laughter yes now
um ike i've been dreaming about
something other than hanging out
which is you
make my personal favorite food in the
whole world and we've talked about this
since our first hang together we have a
business plan that involves this food
and it's should we tell them what it is
yes
it's stuffing oh this is my favorite
food in the world
and you make a famous pastrami stuffing
i do and
it tastes like a reuben sandwich and a
stuffing somehow had a child
and that child was delicious
and is it true your wife erica likes to
have a regular stuffing as well
i put out two stuffings and everyone
goes hog wild for the pastrami stuffing
and my wife i think just to be different
it's like i prefer this classical stuff
so we're in couples therapy we're trying
to work it out
[Music]